hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his article what is philosophy
as a way of life john sellers provide
some very helpful clarifications
and a typology now why do we need this
this term philosophy as a way of life
has been thrown around a lot in recent
decades
it also sometimes corresponds to
earlier discussions about this in other
philosophers or people within the
broader
culture going back several centuries
and i would say there's a lot of
confusion about precisely what
philosophy as a way of life consists in
and so providing an overview and a
typology
of different views on that is
is very helpful clarificatory work so
at the very beginning of the article
john sellers
says that the phrase is closely
associated with the french philosopher
and scholar of ancient philosophy
pierre ardeau whose work gained
prominence in the english-speaking world
in 1995 with the publication of a book
called
philosophy as a way of life
and so you could say that that
crystallized a lot of uh
discussions about this sort of thing
and gave a lot of people the impression
that that hadoa is sort of the central
person and you know if you read hado's
work of course there's lots and lots of
references
to ancient philosophy but his conception
of philosophy is a way of life is not
just confined
ancient philosophy he's willing to you
know consider
all sorts of people all the way up to
say the existentialist movement
as engaging in philosophy as
a way of life so the way that uh seller
summarizes this is
in the chapter from which the volume
gets its title haddo claims that in
antiquity
philosophy was a way of life a motive
existing in the world which had to be
practiced at each instant
the goal of which was to transform the
whole of the individual's life
philosophy is conceived as a love of
wisdom and wisdom haddo says does not
merely cause us to know it causes us to
be
in a certain way and this is a very
helpful way of talking about ancient
philosophy
and what was going on in there ado is of
course not the only person
singling this out you know maurice
blondell
already back in you know the 1890s and
then in his teaching is talking about
uh you know how philosophy has to be
lived through action
and using uh classical examples aleister
mcintyre would be another prime example
right you know still alive today but
working
uh definitely at the same time as i do
talking about tradition
constituted rationalities from after
virtue on
so it's not a radically new idea but
there is something
that that is is valuable in bringing
this out
views philosophy in this sense
philosophy is a way of life
as an art of living and
you know sellers ends up saying that
this is
this can be understood as something that
happened
in this ancient conception of philosophy
different than than doing philosophy uh
as it's often done today
uh he says the important point for the
present purposes is
not only how philosophy was one
conceived
long ago but also here's where we get
the popularity of philosophy as a way of
life
a live metaphilosophical option
that has been taken up by philosophers
throughout the history of philosophy
and can still be taken up today so what
does that mean a meta philosophical
option this is a philosophical
conception of what philosophy is about
what it's doing and this is actually
touching on a really central
issue which is that philosophy if you go
and look for a definition of it any
definition you get is going to be
wrong in the sense that most
philosophers are not going to accept
your definition most practitioners of
the discipline
will not accept any particular
definition that you put forward
this is a historical fact about
philosophy but also points to something
quite important that that's a subject
for another conversation
so it's okay to do metaphilosophy with
the understanding that what we're doing
is taking a particular
view on what philosophy is and what it
could do and what it should do
sellers says this is all good let's see
if we can flesh this conception out
a little bit more and so he's making
some
additional contributions to the
conversation he says
i take philosophy as a way of life to
involve the following things
first that the ultimate motivation of
philosophy is to transform
one's way of life now notice he doesn't
say just one's life
one's way of life that's quite important
second that there should be some
connection and consistency between
somebody's
stated philosophical ideas and their
behavior they
as we say don't just talk the talk they
walk the walk so if you're going to do
philosophy as a way of life
it doesn't mean that there has to be a
perfect coincidence between these
but there better be some effort to make
that make sure that there's some
consistency going
between what it is that you're endorsing
and what it is that you're actually
doing
i think that's that's that cannot be
reinforced enough
and then the third thing he says actions
are ultimately more philosophically
significant
than words to the point that it's
possible to determine
someone's set of philosophical beliefs
by examining
their biography and behavior very
interesting point there isn't that that
means that
the way in which a person lives and
what we know about them is
you know not just sort of extra stuff
but it's
directly important for assessing
whether they believe certain things so
these are some really great ways of as
he says flushing the conception out
throughout the rest of the paper
he is examining and working out a number
of different
viewpoints that he summarizes close to
the end
and he tells us here we go that there
are
in light of what we've discussed so far
we might point to three distinct views
about philosophy as a way of life and
these
represent you could say polar positions
that some people within the if there is
a movement of philosophy as a way of
life
some people emphasize more than others i
think he's
completely right to single these out as
distinct views
so the first one philosophy as a way of
life
is a distinct tradition in western
philosophy
different in form and motivation from
both analytic
and continental philosophy dominant in
antiquity and present ever since
albeit marginalized in recent times
so this goes to the part of the paper
where he's talking about well
is it a third way to analytic and
continental philosophy
which are at least in the anglo-american
sphere and arguably in european
philosophy
pretty much the dominant paradigms for
how philosophy
ought to be done we often talk of the
analytic continental
divide right as if that's that's a real
thing and it is sociologically real in
certain
uh certain degrees there's a lot more
that can be said about that but we're
going to skip over that
so is it a distinct tradition
we might actually think of it as a
distinct set of interlocking
traditions that are often in
communication with themselves i'll
mention
again aleister mcintyre who has done so
much
for arguing the need to have a new
aristotelian uh sort of tradition that
that is
you know rooted in a community and
practices and all that
and then anthony long's wonderful
article where he says
you know mcintyre you're perfectly right
about the aristotelians but you're wrong
in pushing the stoics to the side
because the stoics are doing the same
sort of thing they're sort of like a
parallel
tradition and we know there's a lot of
confluence between them
in ancient times as well so you know
it is definitely a a different way a
different approach
to what's typically understood as
analytic and continental philosophy
i think john sellers is right in saying
well i don't want to call it entirely a
third
way there's there's some problematic
aspects of that there's all sorts of
third ways we could say
well what about classical american
philosophy what about
you know uh comparative philosophy what
about
uh we can go on and on and on obviously
the analytics and continentals
although they'd like to say that they're
the only games in town they're not
and so i think sellers is right that
philosophy as a way of life
cuts across the divide as a matter of
fact
i would go so far as to say that you can
find some analytic philosophers in the
history of analytic philosophy
who are clearly engaged in
philosophy as a way of life john wisdom
is a prime example although john wisdom
is of course
reading sartre and engaging not just
with with you know wittgenstein but also
a psychoanalysis and things like that
so you know i i would say he's right in
saying we don't have a monolithic block
of analytic philosophy and then
continental philosophy and then some
third way
between the two distinct view number two
philosophy is a way of life is a
humanist approach
contrasted to be contrasted with a
scientific approach and as such
perhaps sharing more in common with the
work of some continental philosophers
than it does with most analytic
philosophy and the
two paradigms that sellers is using
for this humanistic approach and the
what he's calling a scientific approach
here
are uh socrates and aristotle you know
aristotle
is primarily interested in knowing um
he does have ethics but of course in the
nick of mccain ethics in book 10
contemplation is the best kind of life
so it kind of trumps things
and there's a very strict separation
between the the
theoretical and the practical you know
two different kinds of truth
so you know i think he he's he's uh
right in distinguishing these um
now we should mention so what what sort
of things would they have
in common with continental philosophy
and what continental philosophies
committed marxism he brings up he talks
about existentialism
those arguably our philosophies as ways
of life as well as continental
philosophies right
if we're talking about structuralism and
a lot of post-structuralist stuff
probably not so much right so
you know that's that's worth keeping in
mind sellers also wants to
stress a key point here that i think is
is
very important not to leave out the
motivation
of figuring out what the good life is
and
transforming oneself towards the good
life cannot leave
out what is distinctive to philosophy
and one of the things that is
distinctive to philosophy
in addition to say being an art of
living
is a motivation of
knowing and articulating truth
so if it becomes i'm going to have the
good life but i'm going to do so by
believing in all sorts of things that
aren't true now you're not doing
philosophy as a way of life
and and all the classical
representatives of philosophy as a way
of life
for example the stoics or you know
socrates that say
you're not doing it right you're you're
actually just trying to make yourself
feel okay
and so you know this prevents philosophy
as a way of life from being turned into
sort of a
feel-good consumer item right philosophy
is the philosophy brand so it can't be
at the expense of the commitment to
truth
this is also going to affect the
distinct
view number three philosophy as a way of
life
is one poll or one
aspect inherent to all philosophy
sometimes marginalized but always
present to a greater or lesser extent
i think we have to read in here that
it's a therapeutic
poll because that's part of what he was
discussing
in the section preceding that there is
this sense that philosophy
is the therapy for the soul right and
that
has been a motivation in philosophy
for a you know from the very inception
and going on uh down to the present
oftentimes it is
marginalized people are like oh you know
philosophy is not about feelings at all
no actually a lot of philosophy is about
feelings you know including including
aristotle who thought that
feelings and emotions were quite
important uh that's why heidegger you
know
in being in time tells us that
in rhetoric book two aristotle carried
out one of the first hermeneutics of the
of the emotions right and thought that
that was relevant a bit of a side note
there
sellers again reinforces the very
important point that we don't
want to lose the motivation
of truth and turn everything
just into feel good or feel better
therapy we you know we have to confront
reality
and the promise of philosophy as a way
of life is that
actually by confronting reality and
working through the difficult things
we might actually wind up in a better
state than if we just
you know engaged in soporifics and
self-helpy
you know self-affirmation or whatever
whatever it's gonna be
little band-aid patches um things real
therapy like epictetus says
you know entering into the philosophy
uh whatever it is teaching hall is like
going to see the doctor and remember
back then there was no anesthetics
you know and going to see a doctor was
something a lot of people tried to avoid
just as much as
in the present it's going to be painful
but it's ultimately going to be better
for you
as somebody who's got some skill and
knowledge helps you
work things out instead of for your body
for for your soul
or for your mind or personality so
you know each of these distinct views
represents something about the discourse
of philosophy as a way of life
in really good literature on philosophy
as a way of life all of these tend to be
playing some role but i think that
sellers is right to
disentangle these from each other so we
can assess
the ideas involved in this very
interesting and ongoing movement
you